we are now learning something we
many of us worried about and suspected
which is that millions of coronavirus
vaccine doses
are what the daily beast is describing
as
likely lost in the system
of vaccine distribution although
exactly what that means when you have
such malicious players involved
as trump himself jared kushner and
others
is a real question um the biden
administration found out very quickly
when they took over
that there really was no plan for
vaccine distribution
despite all of the claims about we've
got the best generals and logistics and
all of this different stuff
there really was no serious plan turned
over
to the biden administration for
continued distributions of vaccines
and now it is appearing as though there
are millions of doses
just missing and the answer hasn't yet
emerged
what we know is that according to data
from the cdc
at the time of the daily beast's report
on this
41.4 million doses had been handed out
to states
and only 21.8 million had been
administered
so that means there's 20 million doses
in theory given to states but not yet
administered officials say they believe
there is a surplus somewhere but it's
not clear
how much of a surplus there is because
even though you hear those numbers well
there must be 20 million doses sitting
around
states are saying we're out of vaccines
we don't know
we don't know where these numbers are
coming from but we don't have vaccines
sitting around we're
giving out doses in some cases almost as
quickly as they come in
so biden's coronavirus task force
members
went back and looked at the numbers
again they looked at local data they
looked at federal data here's what
federal data says was given to states
here's what local data says they have
and
they looked at is it a manufacturing
problem is it a shipping problem
is it a receiving problem is it a
waiting around to be administered
problem what's in warehouses what's in
in hospitals for example
they can't figure out what's going on
and every data set that they look at
is missing something and then when they
look at a data set from a different
source
it sort of overlaps but it's
inconsistent it's incongruent
and what they've what they've chalked it
up to so far are what they are calling
quote incredible inefficiencies
and i have to tell you that my
suspicions my fears i think is
better said are that this is
significantly worse
than that um were there lies told about
availability by the trump administration
right and so what they claimed to have
sent to states
they didn't because there weren't
actually the numbers available that they
claimed that would be
maybe incompetence and dishonesty but
not criminality
the other fear of course is were
some of these doses delivered to the
federal government
and then something was done with them
i'm not saying jared kushner is selling
doses to who knows where
at least i don't have evidence of that
at this point in time but is there some
kind of
skimming that has been taking place at
this point
everything is on the table because the
numbers just don't make sense the
numbers just don't add up
and right now biden administration
officials are taking the
the point of view that based on what
they
know right now it seems to be a
combination
of shipping delays and
kinks in reporting so that here's an ex
here's like the most benign possible
example
uh tech i'm making these numbers up
texas gets 10 million doses on paper
federal government says we gave you 10
million doses
texas gets them and then sends them
right back out to hospitals
and hospitals get the 10 million doses
but it takes them a while to report on
the number
administered so a hospital gets a
hundred thousand
and they administer eighty thousand and
they don't yet report
that they've administered the eighty
thousand they just say listen we only
see twenty thousand available doses the
eighty thousand that were administered
haven't yet been reported as
administered
that would be like the most benign
explanation on the other side of it are
really really horrible uh hypotheses
about wrongdoing malfeasance
falsification of orders
skimming and all sorts of things that
seem very jared kushner if you're
familiar with his
track record as a landlord in new york
city in the new york city area
the other possibility is that
they didn't steal anything but things
have been lost or things have been
spoiled
and they didn't want to come clean about
spoilage we know anecdotally of stories
about
uh a pharmacist in i don't remember what
state maybe wisconsin or michigan
deliberately spoiled some doses because
he's some kind of anti-vaxxer and he's
been charged
we know about some number of doses that
uh
cleaning i think it was in boston a
cleaning person accidentally unplugged
one of the
freezers that are used and a bunch of
vaccines spoiled
and those there are reports of maybe
there's some bigger spoilage issue
or loss issue and it's not it's not
being reported i don't know
what it increasingly does seem like
though is that
it's not that there are just millions of
doses sitting
under a table somewhere and any day now
we're going to find them and say oh the
numbers all add up perfectly with every
day that passes without answers to
what's going on
um the the idea that they're just going
to find these
becomes less and less likely so you know
i'm not saying check the freezers at
mar-a-lago
but when it comes to the trump
administration and the dishonesty
i wouldn't put anything past them is the
point and hopefully at some point we're
going to get some answers about what
happened here the good news is
and if you watched yesterday's joe biden
a press event with me
you saw joe biden say that they are
going to be upping vaccine
uh distribution from 8.6 million doses a
week to 10 million doses a week that's
going to get us closer
not quite to 1.5 million per day but in
the 1.2 million area
we have the jnj one dose vaccine that is
supposedly just a week or so
from presenting data to the cdc and
hopefully we'll get approval there it is
plausible
and hopefully increasingly likely that
joe biden is right in what he said
yesterday that during spring
anyone who wants a vaccine will be able
to get one we're going to follow it
we've been following it and
i'll keep you posted as far as that goes
if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already
read or use it to preview a book before
you buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video